twitter でですねよく僕の偽物を見ます肇社長の偽物を楽しんでいる人も入っ
たら中にはなんか危ない url 危ないサイトに飛ばして何だろうな儲けようとし
てるのかな
偽物ってあんまり良くないと思ってるんですよ本当に間違えちゃってる人もいるし
それでなんか危ないことに巻き込まれたりの方が来られたりしたらすごい悪いことだと
思うんで僕は偽物ゆる
じゃないです絶対な僕のツイッターなかったこれだけですこれだけしか使ってません
それ以外のデータ全部偽物だと思っててください新しくできたちゃんと言いますので
これからも twitter もよろしくお願いしますということで今回なんですけど
もうちょっと特殊な事例がありますか購入て来ずで僕の視聴者さんちょっと騙そうとし
ている強く人が入ったんで今日ちょっと成敗してるなと思いますねよそっとまず
ちょっと
まずで成敗してるかてか今回の手口なんですけども肇社長という偽物じゃなくて僕の音
を装った偽モノがと言いますはいこちらなんですけども
旬物を19敗大学生バスケ始め社長の自分の弟です
まだ全体始めたばかりですよろしく4月から youtube 動画10日始めますね
負けたがお菓子俺の力を組み専務でもだめだ
んですけど俺の弟にまで迷惑かけられたらたまったんですよこれはねちょっと許せ
なかった村でちょっと騙されている視聴者さんが多いんですけどみなさんも本当にし
づらいてくださいよ危ないよ変な事に巻き込まれたら大変だから騙される人も多かった
非常に強いと思う
ぞれの弟旬って名前じゃないちょっとつぶやきを見ていくんですけどもう
twitter 始めました
肇社長のまずの音です新部長というのを前に4月から youtube に動画投稿し
てきますよろしくお願いします
そんなに日ツイートしてるんですよここはレッドゾーンてね基本信じちゃダメだと思っ
てくる村が固まりなところあるから皆さんの情報で疾患三比べる力をつけてます
家族にフォローした人も
いるみんなと仲良くなりたいして兄貴に負けないくらいすごくなり実は昔から俺も u
2やりたいと言ってたんだ
何気には止められたけど俺は本規約の3年間ネタを色々考えた
ジャコウ近くだしこれからも考える地月から毎日塔子するよ僕言ってみたんですよ
youtube 今が始めてなんか俺と一緒に行ったら登録車のベルかもしれないよっ
て言ったらあっさり興味ないんですってよ
たのではれたちょっとクールボーイなんですよね dm とが気軽に贈ってな俺も見た
と繋がりたいからもう
di 中古さあてこのタイミングで僕昨日こいつにでプライを送ったんですよなにせ町
迷惑してますやめてくださいって送ったんですけどそれからの金のつぶやきです暗示の
せいで真似てるか歯科に力をかしてくれなくていいって言ったけど何しましたが本当
冗談通じない
もう立場がいいなすごいなこれも始めようか実は編集を張っているとかが一つ荒れて
35人文字ツイートしてる人がいるっていう
もう俺から言えることはきょうつけてるとしか言えないですというまた作品としては
フォローしてみましょう
フォロワーさんも100人もいますから遅れた遅れた送り出すと僕が弟と信じたら感じ
でいきましょう
味
n
俺のん
ずっとんぞこのまずは向こうの手形をうかがいましょう
愛甲のフレだからちょっと過ぎには帰って来なさそうなので様子見です
おはようございます次の日の朝ですなんと税額きました
3時間前ですね大きさ気だおい怒ってないよとか俺のセリしゃぶのな理由ありすぎ
マテ待てマテ待てこいつ僕はもうね本当のことを言うべきかなぁ
いやまだちょっと凝っておこう頑張れよ集応援してるよと気
本当に成り切ってるんだね
ブーブーメッツ振っ
大これはすごいなあアティヤ本当にひぁっにょ使い着圧モノデイズ
許せ北いつも
トートと円楽するときラインで話してるんでちょっと来院を返してもらいたいという
要求をしている
なかなかちょっと経つが悪いかも知れ託した納刀となんだと思ってるんだこれさあこの
dm をスクショして多分つぶやきたかったんで何度もガチで会話する見せかけて
まわりの人を煎じさせるっていう心理的な作戦かも知れませんってのはちょっとそれと
ここで帰って来ない作戦あります
4んどうしてはちょっと相手のはれてるだけでどれがここら辺にして
ちょっと攻めてみましょう俺の弟あじゃあ俺がオートになっちゃった
こんな没頭との名前は
うちは彼の
弟なのか
可能店
教えてくれこれでまたで旬って名前じゃないってことを教えたのと
僕ちょっとまだふざけちゃったんですけどこのマルヒ崎に乗るかどうかというところ
ですね
没泊まってみましょう
あれから少し時間なかったんですけども少し進展がありました
ご支援部ツアーのつぶやきが新しく植えました
こちらですねあ日も最初は反対だったのに応援してくれた
反対としたことないんだけど頑張れよ新望遠してるよタッチ僕の答えているのいい
ところだけ使ってますところで大宴会してくれないの手前までしか使ってるっていう
100万先方のつべえてならたぶん僕のこの dm 見てるんですよとなると言ってる
んだ論集
多分こっそり作ったんですけどねが使い道がなかったのでここで使ってあげましょう
ua
こんなにレイヤー何動画に見れないからね試合はに専門アカウントで悪いことをして
いるのですごい待遇だよ限定動画を見せてどう反応するかですね
絶対見てると思うんだけど
なかなか返事が来ないですね駄目ですねなかなかちょっと帰って来ないしてね
もうちょっと待ってみましょう
はいというわけでさっきの別姓時間2時間が経過しました
2時間経ったんですけどいまだにちょっと変え室つもりがないみたいです
いろいろ超頑張って書き込んでみたんですけど今市子反応がないん
じゃあ絶対見てるんですがこいつの釣り大臣と言ってみましょう
こいつは注ぐ8人とか行くとなんかちゃんと僕との dm をまた貼ってるんですよ
これ
単16分日がかまってちゃんが半端ない釜座おいらの dm と寝るというもの
つぶやいってもう何だろう
こいつイヤーあくどいなーおいだの dm は返さないでつぶやき予算とするって言う
この先の進展が見られませんだ dm 返さないとこいつ喋っ子がないんだよ
今回の牧童トート偽物の調査ここまで書
始めゲームズくらいなんか返してくれてもいいと思うなんだ完璧なんが俺が悪いやつ
みたいなちゃってる
じゃあちょっとねあの今
は僕が言いたかったのはまあなりすまんしする奴らたぶんこの先も増えると思います
ロックじゃなくて僕の例えば弟とかねそういう偽物はすごい増えてくるんですけど皆
さんは絶対信じないでください確実に偽物です
もうこの2つ以外は全部偽物です間違いなくちゃうわけでちょっと虹ものセイバー
しようと思ったんですけどなかなか動きがするぞ
てい
ってケバくないか変化があったら連絡しようと思いますそして見かけたらやめるように
言ってあげてくださいじゃん